alright welcome back everybody so the
early birds get more information here's
who there's a i wish i had a prize i
actually don't know but thank you for
coming back did everybody have a good
lunch food was great I before we get
started started I just wanted to remind
you about the websites I had a lot of
conversation with people and some I
talked with David Stone who's our vice
president for communications and he
mentioned a few things to me that I
thought were interesting write this down
if you you know and it may be in your
materials columbia.edu to go straight to
the columbia alumni association website
its alumni dot columbia.edu you also can
get to that site on columbia edu by
going to that site and clicking on
alumni and then there are lots of other
things that the things that we've been
talking about today manhattanville for
example some of the community
initiatives there's a section on the
website on columbia.edu Columbia in New
York if you click that on and you
navigate a little bit you'll find
hundreds of local New York initiatives
places where the university is involved
so please take a look at that there and
and david has also promised me that
after this conference that we will send
you a list of links some of the things
that we've been talking about so that
you'll be able to click on because we
don't want to lose the excitement and
the enthusiasm and feeling I know
sometimes you have to give folks stuff
and because you may not think about put
it to clicking that on I also just in by
walking around today you know that we're
being videotaped and there's going to be
something on the website and Joe Turner
Lynn and I don't know if Jojo may be
shooting and maybe not able to raise his
hand but he's Columbia College 96 and
School of the Arts up oh four and he has
been video in this he says he's going to
have about forty four hours a video at
the end of it that'll turn into several
small short pieces and he tours have you
been filming he said well Sundance
you know Columbia has an annual party at
Sundance with 24 this year there were 25
films done either by students faculty or
alumni and he also was at art basel so I
mean that's the Columbia's everywhere
and I some of you may have been in New
York last fall when we had the assembly
leaders assembly a fabulous event at
Lincoln Center and you know lots of
conversations on campus so there are all
kinds of things going on again
columbia.edu will help you find those
things now I also wanted to just as we
bring a Dean moody Adams out she's going
to be doing a panel on students and I
mentioned to you earlier today that i
had read a month's worth of the columbia
spectator they sort of pile up and I
then I get a chance to read them but
here the things some of the things that
I learned a record number of women
students rushed sororities this year
that wasn't happening when I was there I
read the series of rotc ROTC forums and
you can go to the Columbia spectator
website and read those things so
questions that you may have had about
the process of the ROTC decision you can
find there for Washington people this is
important a five guys is coming to the
neighborhood at Columbia at a hundred
eleventh and broadway students are
worried about hooking up whether they
are in the it's complicated category on
facebook or whether they're writing
spectator comes about their weekend
dates with what I think is way too much
information students praised the
commencement speaker and students
criticized the commencement speaker so
as president Bollinger said earlier
today everything is debated on campus so
this and you're going to hear lots of
really more important things from the
panel who's coming up so it's my
pleasure to introduce Dean Michelle
moody Adams who is Dean of Columbia
College and Henry L and Lucy G Moses
professor she is also vice president for
undergraduate education before coming to
columbia dean moody adams was vice
provost for undergraduate education at
cornell as well as a professor of
philosophy and director
and Hutchinson professor and Cornell's
program on ethics and public life she
did her undergraduate degree at
Wellesley College a second ba at Oxford
University and received her MA and PhD
in philosophy from Harvard University
she is not just an administrator but a
much-loved teacher day Michelle moody
apps thank you so much alike I'm
delighted to be back with you again this
afternoon so we were here to celebrate
Columbia's leadership in the world part
of that leadership is a function of what
the institution does in New York City
and morningside heights and Washington
Heights and soon in manhattanville part
of it is what our alumni accomplished
and we heard from several of our really
distinguished alums this morning and the
third part is what our current students
are accomplishing and experiencing and I
have to say you are in for a real treat
this afternoon with us are three of our
most accomplished current students who
are about to leave Colombia at the end
of this academic year so we're excited
to have the chance to sort of learn a
bit from them about what they'll take
with them as they go out into the world
to become leaders in the world as well
and the three students are Laura Kelly
on the far end who is 2011 in public
health she will complete her mph degree
in 2011 may in socio medical sciences
and global health with the concentration
on sexual and reproductive health and
gender issues she received her BA in
health policy and anthropology at Rice
University in 2008 and she will be a
rotary international ambassador scholar
ambassadorial scholar sorry to Tanzania
visiting research fellow at MU humbly
university and shall study contraception
and adolescent issues next to me is sara
khan CC class of 2011 she's a senior
that is at the college she's an
interdisciplinary major in econ
comics and political science and she
also has a concentration in sustainable
development which we heard about earlier
this morning she is an undergraduate
fellow at the institute for social and
economic research and policy and she's
also editor of the undergraduate journal
of South Asian Studies and in the middle
is Tao chan who is class of 2007
Columbia College and also Business
School class of 2011 so another double
Colombian he's about to complete an MBA
in May of 2011 with a focus on finance
he has a Bachelor of Arts in economics
and history from columbia college that
was 2007 and he has been serving as
student body chair of the University
Senate and he'll be going in me when he
leaves Columbia to join the bank of
america merrill lynch in new york city
so welcome to all of you we are
delighted to be able to share some time
with you today and I thought I would
start by asking you to each of you to
reflect a little on what you've learned
or done at Columbia that you think has
prepared you to lead in the world when
we start with Sarah i think i would
start first and foremost with my
experiences with the core curriculum
because that really has been the
cornerstone of my undergraduate
experience at columbia I think the class
contemporary civilization in radicular
was very inspiring for me and it
developed in me and love for political
philosophy and I'm actually hoping to
continue studying political science and
i'll be back at columbia in the fall to
start my PhD in the political science
department and i think it was
contemporary civilization that sparked
that interest in me and i also think
that one of the most important things
about columbia which is its diverse
student body is reflected really well in
the core curriculum classes all core
curriculum classes are small and
discussion
based and it's very interesting to see
the different perspectives that students
can bring to the table about one text or
one piece of art or one piece of music
and the conversations that I've had in
these classes have been extremely
valuable to me and I think it's the best
taste of Columbia that you can get is by
sitting in on one of these core
curriculum classes second of all I would
say would be the opportunities for
research that I've had at Columbia
during my undergraduate career and as an
undergraduate fellow at the institute
for social and economic research and
policy I've had the chance to work with
a professor sociology on her project on
immigration and wages and I'm now
developing my own independent study
project to study taxi drivers and their
wages and the barriers to entry in that
profession in New York City so I'm very
excited about that and I think last of
all I would like to speak about the way
that community engagement has been dyed
in with my classes at Columbia and do
instances of this in particular are the
current sustainable development workshop
that I'm taking which is a capstone
workshop for the concentration and
sustainable development and as part of
this workshop the sustainable
development concentrators are developing
a curriculum on climate change for new
york city urban park rangers to teach to
students who come to new york city parks
and it's a very exciting opportunity to
get involved in an educational end of
her and also have a chance to see New
York's urban parks which I hadn't had a
chance to visit most of them before this
class and last semester I took a seminar
in human rights
and one of the parts of that seminar was
to volunteer with the International
Rescue Committee and work with the
refugee and as I Lee population of New
York City so I think the exposure to the
community around me that Colombia has
provided through the classes in a very
structured way actually has been
essential to my education it's great
thank you so much Sarah tau you want to
tell us a bit about your leadership
experiences Thank You Dean moody Adams
well I would say that the most important
thing I would take away from Columbia
that would inform my leadership going to
the future is absolute openness to
different points of views different
ideas etc at Columbia College for
example I think it's pretty clear that I
believe in capitalism but in the core
curriculum I was forced to while sorry I
gladly red marks Oh had lively
discussions with justice committed
marxists and in the business school
right now for example where where
finance is a predominant theme in the
business school education nonetheless
I'm an almond class with people from
nonprofit backgrounds from government
backgrounds from you know general
management in manufacturing backgrounds
so what I would say that all these
things have done for me it's given me an
opportunity to appreciate different
views and specifically in the field I
will go into finance after graduation
how that applies is this I've become
very cognizant of the philosophical view
but the purpose of finance may not be
well sorry purpose of Finance maybe to
facilitate to develop to catalyze to
bring about the development of Industry
and sometime in the last 20 or so years
finance became an industry in and of
itself and there are many who say that
the mess that we are digging ourselves
out of right now may be linked to that
view so as I go forward into the world
as a banker these are the views that an
education at Columbia in both Columbia
College and Columbia Business School
have opened me up to and they will form
part of my decisions and certainly
inform whatever leadership positions
I'll be fortunate not to take in the
future accordingly
so Laura tell us a bit about your
experiences sure one thing that's been
really neat at mailman is the
interdisciplinary focus which i think is
so important in public health because
not only are you applying research from
multiple disciplines but also working
with stakeholders who come from all
different fields and in particular in
the socio medical sciences department
there's a really rigorous application of
social theory to identify the processes
that shape vulnerability to health and
that's really given me a strong
technical and contextual background for
working abroad especially with with my
background in sexual and reproductive
health and also I've participated in
student leadership opportunities there's
been leadership training at the American
Public Health Association I've had an
opportunity to present a poster there as
well as travel to present at a
conference in France at a university of
public health in Oakland that Colombia
recently signed a partnership with which
was a really neat experience to
collaborate with professionals in my
field that come from a country where the
context of how health care is provided
is extremely different and also like
Sarah there's been an opportunity to
interact with the community the
Dominican community in Washington
Heights where mailmen is located and
last spring break student group actually
took a trip to dominican republic to do
nutrition work which was really
interesting because it was one small
component of a partnership between
mailmen the Dominican community in
Washington Heights and the Dominican
Republic which has several research
projects at Columbia your heads and and
takes forward with collaboration with
partners in the Dominican Republic but
also students from the dr are coming to
mailmen and to the Columbia Medical
Center to study so getting to be part of
that community was really neat that's
great one theme that ran through a lot
of what we heard this morning was the
presence that the institution has as
well as many of our projects and plans
on the global stage and I wonder if any
of the panelists today would tell us
about
national experiences they've had would
you mind I came back to you first yeah
sure one really unique part of the
global health program at maleman and
they are the only program in the country
that offers this is a six-month
international practicum which i
completed in senegal so i was living in
da car for six months working at the
local partner of an international
organization that focuses on family
planning and Senegal has an extremely
high unmet need for contraception and a
high rate of more turnham of maternal
mortality so it was very interesting
work and in particular I was working on
an adolescent sexual health program
which in terms of the social changes
that are happening in a lot of urban
centres in developing countries
adolescents education health issues are
really at the crux of that so it was an
incredible experience and not only did I
get to have it but I came back this
semester with 30 classmates who had been
in Cambodia Tanzania Uzbekistan and got
to talk to them about their
cross-cultural experiences it was really
unique it's great you make me want to be
a student you can even town tell us a
bit about your international sure I one
of my greatest regrets in Columbia
colleges I never studied abroad but this
past winter with Columbia Business
School with 20 of my classmates I went
on a program which is the business
school is known as the chazen
international study tour now that works
is it takes about 20 students and it
puts them in another country where they
meet with the you know government
officials and business leaders and go
visit companies during a day and you
know do other stuff at night but that
was that was a trip and the trip I went
on was to Cairo and to Dubai and this is
around mid-january we I will remember
this for the rest of my life we went to
go visit the now former Deputy Minister
of Finance who is a CEO alum and a
member of my group raised his hand and
said mr. Minister in Egypt you have
700,000 nuga new college graduates a
year and you know job creation is a
problem and what is your use to this how
can a jip address this and the minister
was very ministerial he said you were
correct this is a problem however
this is mid-january I do not believe
this will lead to political instability
oh wow you had a front-row seat to
history there that's amazing so sarah
tells us to meet about your
international experience sure um so I
first stepped on to columbia's campus
about three and a half years ago coming
straight from Islamabad Pakistan so the
past few years have been like an
extended study abroad for me but I
haven't actually gone away from from
Columbia to study abroad with her
destination but I did do a very exciting
summer program through the columbia
center for career education in the
summer of 2009 and this was a program in
collaboration with the scottish
government it's called encouraging
dynamic global entrepreneurs program and
a cohort of 16 Columbia students
partnered with students from the
University of Glasgow and we provided
consulting services to small businesses
in glasgow scotland and it was really
interesting to see not only the
different work culture but also interact
with young entrepreneurs in scotland and
we also had the opportunity to create
and present our own small business plans
um so my cohort my group and I focused
on a business plan for a children's
literacy center in Glasgow so it was a
social entrepreneurship program and it
was a great experience for me so
wonderful so cal i want to ask you to
start us off on the topic of how your
activity on the campus has allowed you
to engage other students as a leader and
in leadership oh sure Thank You Dean
Williams well as the Moody Adams
mentioned one of the roles that I take
on is the student body chair of the
University Senate which I'm sure you all
know yesterday voted to make sure I get
this correct endorse the president to
begin negotiations on the return of rotc
right all right and there are challenges
and there are opportunities in a body
like that in the Senate it's the only
body at Columbia where every single
student from every sing
school and there are 19 constituent in
philly ated schools of columbia are
represented so in the committee did I
chair known as the Student Affairs
Committee you have students from 19
wildly different schools coming together
in one room and a key challenge is
always how do you get them interested in
one issue how what does a columbia
college student have in common with a
student from the College of Dental
Medicine it's a good question and what
we found in the past year is that there
are some issues of such importance and
such impact to the institution that
properly leveraged these this group of
students which is unique at Columbia can
be a tremendous resource and over the
past few months you know we couldn't we
conducted a process to investigate our
OTC public hearings you know email
submissions a student body survey that
would not have been possible except for
the gathering of so many minds from so
many different backgrounds in one room
and you know I can I'm very proud of
this by the way it's that the result
that we've pulled off is the most public
the most publicized the most open and
one of the most transparent inquiries an
rotc of any major university in this
country that is a reflection of what
students can do excellent Thank You
Laura can you tell us what him about
your engaging of other students yeah
sure while i've been at mailman I've
been president of the global health
forum actually John Ezra young ma
preceded me in that position in he's
attending today which is really neat to
connect and that gave us the opportunity
to connect with male meant alums and
also professionals in New York and bring
them to the campus which is at 168
street so it's no small task to tell
students about what they're doing since
much of public health is so applied and
we're busy in school we don't always get
a chance to see the the full breadth of
what professionals in our field are
working on so specifically we
implemented a somatic framework last
year we did Health and Human Rights we
brought in a lot of people from from
Human Rights Watch and working with
George rep at the International
Committee to speak and I also serve as a
board member on the Columbia partnership
for International Development which has
students across all of the graduate
schools that have a
steak in international development
including the business school sepa
Social Work Teachers College maleman and
that also was really neat to collaborate
across disciplines and find an issues
like climate change what are the
perspectives that students are bringing
what interests them what can we
collaborate on to Java the rest of the
student body and i have to say being
involved in extracurricular activities
at Columbia has really made me sharpen
my skills because there's a lot to do in
New York and if you want people to come
you've got to put on some great
programming to draw them in so that's
very true thank you Sarah tell us a bit
about your activity engaging other
students sure um I think one of the
unique opportunities I've had of
Columbia is to engage with prospective
students through my work for the
undergraduate recruitment committee and
at the moment I serve as a senior
interviewer for the recruitment
committee so I'm able to speak to some
of the extremely smart and bounded high
schoolers who apply to columbia and i
had the unique opportunity of
interviewing students who have been
shortlisted for the national opportunity
program which brings in students that
have been historically underrepresented
in colombia's student body as well as
first-generation college students to
columbia and it's a great treat for me
to be able to talk about my experiences
to these students and tell them a little
bit more about columbia and they're
really a very diverse set of students so
you have students who know absolutely
everything about columbia and more
statistics and facts that perhaps any of
us know and then you have students who
have never heard of the core curriculum
and then you tell them a little bit
about it and they're genuinely eager and
excited so it's very exciting to be able
to do that for the recruitment recruit
students and another thing that I do is
serve as an editor on the board of the
Columbia undergraduate journal for South
Asian Studies I was also a founding
member of the journal it's a young
publication
um we just managed to print our issues
for the first time this semester and
that's very exciting previous to this we
were a web-only journal and I think one
of the great challenges with being part
of a publication is getting readership
and engaging students on campus to be
interested in the issues that the
journal reflects and I think one of the
things that Laura spoke about really
having interesting programming to
accompany even a publication is really
important so this semester we're working
on hopefully getting some speaker events
to talk about some of the issues that
have been published in our current
volume so we're hoping to get that going
it's wonderful one of the things that's
so important about the work that Sarah
does on the recruit undergraduate
recruitment committee has helped us
manage those 34,000 students who come in
some way shape or form to express their
interest in applying to Columbia we
heard had a six point four percent
selectivity raid so we keep you busy
with on the tours and so forth before we
open it up to questions I would put it
from the audience I wanted to give our
panelists a chance to answer one last
question it really reflects on both what
they'll take away from Columbia and what
they would like to see incoming students
who study in the same programs
experience while they're here so I'll
start this time maybe with Sarah um I
think all my life the most important
thing about any place for me has been
the people and it's always the people
that make the place and that's been
especially true for my experience at
Columbia because I've had the chance to
meet people from all over the world
whether it be through classes or
extracurricular activities or just
living across the hall and I think that
network of people is something that I'll
really take away and those connections
are something that I hope to mundane and
I think they're going to be absolutely
crucial with my long-term plans I'm
going back to graduate school in the
fall but my long
term goal is to go back to Pakistan and
establish a policy center of sorts that
engages with academics both in Pakistan
and scholars outside of pakistan writing
about or researching pakistan and i
think that the connections that i've
made with students and faculty members
at columbia and the connections i hope
to make in the graduate program will be
absolutely essential to this project
another thing I hope to take from
Colombia is just the spirit of civic
engagement with the community and with
the outside world and i think that
colombia really incorporates the spirit
along with the classes and academics
that go on and I've had a chance to step
out into New York City as part of my
classes which i think is really really
unique and I'm currently volunteering as
a college mentor for high school
students and twice a week I go up to one
hundred and thirtieth an Amsterdam and
teach social studies class a curriculum
on civic engagement and I think it's
really really important to have that
spirit being cultivated not just at the
college level at Columbia but very early
on among middle schoolers and high
schoolers the high schoolers I teach
right now have decided to take up trees
and as their focus issue for this
semester and they're going to start a
community garden in their school so I'm
really really excited about that and I
hope to continue being involved in such
initiatives it's great what I take away
from Columbia is without a doubt a
passionate unquenchable love for
learning what think the one thing you
take a Colombian any of its schools is
that whatever you find whatever you
think you know you want to know a little
more that's been a huge benefit what I'd
like future classes to see at Columbia
that's very easy what are the one thing
I would like future classes to
experience at Columbia University see
the men's football team my beloved Lions
as they have before when the rose bowl
again
oh so Laura yeah I i really want to echo
what Sarah said about the people when i
came to mail man i thought i would get a
professional network in New York but I
really have developed one around the
world and developed skills and cross
cultural fluency that have been really
amazing and I've also been really
inspired by the faculty and the students
at Mahlon to engage with the community
wherever I may be and I live in Brooklyn
right now and I'm volunteering with a
group that is doing programming to
decrease HIV among adolescents of color
among which the rate of HIV is actually
double that of Senegal when I learned
that I couldn't believe it and yeah I've
just been really inspired to to change
the way that healthcare is delivered
around the world to make sure that
marginalized populations have have
access to appropriate technologies and
for incoming students I think I would
tell them to use their alumni because
it's easy to get caught up in school
caught up in learning but a few times
I've looked at the alumni directory and
contacted some people to talk to them
about what they do and it's been
incredibly helpful and everyone that
I've gotten in touch with has been very
receptive so i would encourage students
to take advantage of it that's a
wonderful message so i think we have a
few minutes now to give the audience a
chance to ask these extraordinary
students outstanding Colombians a few
questions I hope we can get the mics
available to people who have questions
question for misc on from this side of
the world it seems as if the position of
women in Pakistan just deteriorates yep
fairly fairly much when you think of
going back home is this a concern of
yours that is something you do need to
think and worry about or is it just
something which is over-exaggerated
here in this country thank you um I
think that it's absolutely a huge
concern for me and before I came to
Columbia um I was part of an
organization that did advocacy for equal
rights for women and we were able to
achieve a change a legislative change in
the hoodoos ordinances which were
extremely discriminatory for women so I
think that there are problems but
there's great space and great need for
change and that's one of my driving
forces for going back to Pakistan and
making hopefully helping see some of
that change happens and I think that one
of my greatest inspirations for going
back is my mother who has been a
professor at a public university in
Pakistan for 25 years and she's
currently the only female in the
economics department at that University
so I've had she's been a very strong
presence in my life and I think that
that really inspires me and tells me
that well she can do it then so can I
it's great that's right I think we have
time for a couple more questions Greg
krasovsky Columbia College of 91 this is
a question to the entire panel as well
to our Dean one of the compelling
reasons that many people want to go to
Columbia and go to Columbia is the fact
that it's in new york new york being the
business in the financial center of our
country but couldn't we do more to
leverage that in terms of the internship
opportunities especially for
undergraduate students i'm sure that
within the business schools in school of
public health they probably have a very
robust program in terms of summer
internships but when I was at Columbia
College you know back then in the day we
really didn't have a formal internship
program that could have been set up by
career services or something like that
and I think that would work to a
tremendous advantage has the situation
changed now Sarah when you look at your
fellow classmates and things like that
sure um well i think that the center for
career education does a wonderful job of
connecting students with internship
both in New York and also around the
world and New York is wonderful for
anyone who wants to go into just about
any sector and my interest in policy led
me to pursue an internship with a
non-profit in New York City last
semester and because of the proximity to
the United Nations there's a lot of
opportunity for engaging with different
agencies of the UN through internships
and my summer internship was unpaid
which was a huge problem because I was
going to be living in New York so
through Columbia I was able to apply for
the Edwin Robbins fellowship for public
service and this allowed me to have a
small stipend I was able to live in New
York and feed myself and through the
unpaid internship so thanks to Columbia
I was able to stay there for the summer
that's great I would also say that a
couple weeks ago I had the good fortune
to attend an event with Dean moody items
called the college to career event and
what this is it's a new initiative on
behalf of the Center for Career
Education that brings together recent
and not so recent is it is that a nice
way of putting yes okay of Columbia
College alums with the current
generation of Columbia students the
group them by their major by their
concentration and I saw this wonderful
interaction going on between you know
the question my father once asked me is
what are you going to do with a history
degree well I wish he went with me to
that event because there was a bunch of
history majors over here doing all sorts
of interesting things and I think the
connections that are being set up
between students and alumni particularly
sir and your question of internships and
job opportunities is something to be
very proud of great thank you we have
time for one very quick question and
then a concise answer Thank You
professor Diane M Falk washington DC a
quick question for Muskaan would you
repeat again the name of your journal
and a more important question from is
Tom it has abstinence-based awareness
programs found a place in any of the
AIDS prevention concern programs
the name of the journal is the Columbia
undergraduate journal for South Asian
Studies thank you currently no not that
I know of but during the period for
which USAID funding for programs that
had to do with abortion was revoked
there were some organizations that
accepted money from USAID and changed
the way that they did their programming
some had adequate funding that they were
able to operate on their own one notable
example is Marie Stopes but i would say
that what we've seen both from the
literature and from my personal
experience is that programs that deal
comprehensively with people's health
needs help them manage their health fest
and in places such as Senegal or
Tanzania both of where I've done some
research we see that in situations where
adolescents are stigmatized and are not
able to attend reproductive health
clinics that there are very high rates
of unsafe clandestine abortions among
teenage girls that get them sick
sometimes the result would be a
hysterectomy death or even miss school
for six months and don't end up going
back so I think the evidence shows that
comprehensive programming achieves the
best health results among a lot a lot of
interesting abstinence-based awareness
promotions yes yeah and very simple
thank you so much for thank you so much
so and please join me in thanking these
outstanding Colombians for their
insights and observations thank you all
so much wonderful
Thank You Dean moody Adams and so now I
have another word to add to my list
excited proud and impressive they were
fabulous and one thing that stuck stuck
out from you and Laura said cross
cultural fluency I mean there's so much
of what we're hearing today about what's
going on campus what's happening with
students some of the new initiatives
that we really are a global university